- I feel like I've spent
this entire vacation walking.
This is what tourism looks like
during the coronavirus pandemic.
It's very busy.
Most rows are quite full.
(people chattering)
It's the biggest crowd I've
been in since lockdown began.
I am lost and I am hot.
As countries reopen their
borders again after lockdowns,
I wanted to see if it was
possible to travel safely.
This is obviously a really lovely way
to get round the city.
So with my editor's permission,
I look a short trip from
London to Barcelona.
But getting here while
feeling safe and relaxed
wasn't as easy as it used to be.
Here's what I learnt.
First off, I wanna know if
traveling's a good idea at all.
So I called, Lena Ciric,
an environmental microbiologist.
Lena, do you think it's
safe to travel right now?
- It is safe to travel.
It is a risk.
But I think if you're wise
and you use a mask well
and you keep washing your hands,
I think it should be okay.
- Lena's agreed to be
my virtual tour guide,
helping to ensure that I don't catch
or spread the virus while I'm traveling.
- I think the measures
that have been imposed
by various governments have
evolved a bit over time.
In a way, we've become more aware
and we now know better
how to deal with this.
- Step one is picking somewhere to go.
Something that I found easy in the past
but is now difficult.
A great resource is the U.S.
State Department's website,
which has information on
rules for each country.
Traveling to Spain for
a holiday, for example,
is not something you can
currently do from the US
but I'm allowed to go from London
as many countries in Europe
have loosened restrictions
after months of lockdowns.
I have to fill out this
contact tracing health form
before I go.
You'll find that some other countries
have a similar approach.
It's also important to check
for specific public health guidelines,
like mandatory quarantines
in any countries
you might be traveling through.
And packing my suitcase
isn't as simple as just
sunscreen and sandals.
- I would probably have
about 10 reusable masks.
Definitely stock up on
some hand sanitizer.
It might be worth taking
some surface wipes.
- I'm taking two types of masks with me.
These homemade cloth masks will be used
when I'm outdoors in uncrowded spaces
but these are N95 medical-grade masks
and these will be used when I'm in crowded
or confined public spaces.
My employer has said I have
to use this when traveling.
Well, that is not comfortable.
Okay, first impressions, it's very clean.
At the airport, baggage drop and security
was similarly clean
with plenty of opportunities for me
to sanitize my hands.
But it's hardly a relaxing
experience wandering
around an airport where there
are huge signs warning you
of the virus at every turn.
I'm starting to go right now
and they've just done an announcement
that says the flight is full.
A big queue's just formed.
Everyone just rushed to the gate to board.
Everyone's bunched over there.
There is a lot of people rushing
to try and get through the gate.
It's very busy.
Most rows, quite full.
That's possibly because while the number
of inter-Europe flights
has risen some 42% since June,
it's still a fraction of how many
were flying pre-pandemic.
British Airways, who I'm flying with,
says it adheres to all guidance
from governments and regulators.
According to Lena,
the air quality in here
could be the safest
of my entire journey.
- From the point of view
of air and ventilation,
planes really are probably
your safest mode of transport.
The air quality in there
is probably the best that you'd find
in any mode of transport,
and probably in most indoor spaces.
Not only do they add about 50% fresh air
but it's also HEPA filtered
and HEPA filters are
basically the gold standard
when it comes to air filtration.
It's just that you're
stuck there for some time
with other people.
- After my plane lands,
I have to pass through Barcelona Airport's
COVID control gate.
I had to show them the QR code
from the form that I filled out.
I didn't have my temperature
taken as I went through.
Spain's Ministry of Health says
that sometimes people are
not aware their temperature
is being taken by thermal cameras.
I have never been happier
to walk into a hotel room.
At my hotel, there are
sanitizing stations throughout
and a one-way system in place.
I can finally take my mask off
for the first time properly
in about three, four hours.
Ah.
But I can't relax just yet.
- Things like bedside tables,
maybe it's a good idea to give
those a little bit of a wipe.
But then things like light switches
and handles and remote controls.
So just the things
that probably won't have
been cleaned thoroughly.
Popping a do not disturb sign on the door
should mean that nobody else comes in
but you'll have to forego a turn down.
I was also told that breakfast
would be served in my room
instead of the usual buffet.
Sightseeing also involves
following a number of rules
that various from place to place.
Even though I'm not in a private area,
I'm still wearing a mask right now.
That's partly for my own safety
and for the safety of others.
But also, it's because if you get caught
without a mask on the street in Spain,
there's an instant 100 euro fine.
It's worth checking with local authorities
to find out what the rules
are at your destination.
To stay safe, I decided
to walk most of the time.
- I think it would be a good idea
to avoid going on public
transport really if you can.
On public transport,
there's many more people
that go through there.
I would say there is a bit
more risk going on a train
because it's less controlled,
because the ventilation system
isn't as sophisticated as
it would be on a plane.
- Walking is nice but it
does take away precious time
from my weekend break.
I feel like I've spent this
entire vacation walking
between the things I want to see,
rather than just enjoying things.
- If you go by taxi,
I mean, again it really
depends on the taxi driver
to some extent.
Are they cleaning between people?
Do they keep their windows open?
- [George] I'm gonna do down
the window if that's okay?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Thank you, sir.
- Were the passengers that
were in there before you,
did they wear masks?
Were they careful?
It's a bit of a gamble.
- I used a taxi to get from
the airport to the hotel
but for longer journeys in the city,
I chose to hire a bike
and just carefully wipe down
the handlebars with sanitizer.
This is actually a really lovely
way to get round the city.
I feel clean, I feel
safe, I've got fresh air.
I'm actually making
quite a bit of progress.
An hour and a half's ride costs me $8.
The virus has even impacted how I dine.
- For restaurants, we've
got two alarm bells.
Potentially lots of people,
potentially an indoor area
with quite a few people in it.
So if possible, and weather permitting,
stick to a table outside if you can.
- That might be quite easy here
and that's for two reasons.
Firstly, Spain enjoys a nice climate
and dining outside is
part of the culture here.
But secondly, because the government
have decried that can open your restaurant
if you have a terrace
area where people can dine
so people don't have to go indoors.
One venue that was allowed to
open was a nearby tapas bar,
owned by Joeri Vanrossi and his partner.
- I think it was three weeks,
only the places with terraces could open.
So we were one of the lucky ones.
- [George] For bars like Joeri's,
even with local residents going out again,
there's a lot riding on
getting travelers to come back.
- We work mainly with tourism
and some, let's say, about 70% of tourism
and 30% local people.
Barcelona without tourism,
it just doesn't work.
- Tourist attractions like
the Sagrada Familia basilica
were closed during my stay.
The crux of the problem is that vacations
are supposed to be relaxing
and it's kinda hard to relax in the midst
of a global pandemic.
The mask wearing, hand sanitizing
and constant reminders of the virus
don't exactly make for a relaxing trip.
But for now, some of these measures
are just the reality of traveling safely.
And most governments and
health experts don't expect
this to change any time soon.
It's worth remembering that for now,
it's impossible to
completely eliminate the risk
of the virus.
So if you're not comfortable traveling,
it's probably best to stay at home.